et on décrypte sous contrat et ce voyage
d'emmanuel macron avec nos deux invités
père connaît ça en scène au
fonctionnaire spécialiste des questions
stratégiques internationales et gérard
vespière analyste géopolitique
fondateurs du web magazine le monde
décrypté
bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
ce soir sur arte france ce dossier de
vente de rafale a donc été suivi par 3
président de la république successifs
nicolas sarkozy françois hollande puis
emmanuel m'a fait parce que la vente
d'avions de combat est une affaire
politique gérard l'espère
oui on peut même remonter plus loin
puisque ça fait maintenant 40 ans que la
france a fourni des avions un militaire
des avions de combat aux émirats arabes
unis donc qui souhaitent une politique
de défense forte à a besoin
effectivement de pouvoir à élaborer des
produits de qualité si ces produits sur
le qualité et bien naturellement à les
pays qui n'ont pas d'industrie de
défense à son à des acheteurs potentiels
donc nous avons connu cela avec la
précédente génération des des mirages
n'est ce pas il ya eu plusieurs
centaines deux mirage fabriqué par la
firme d'assaut côté vendu à
l'exportation
là maintenant nous abordons une première
entre 100 et 200 donc une deuxième
centaine de rafale était bien on est
dans l'histoire
13 ans de négociations mais au final le
contrat est donc conclu c'est le signe
que la france se vend bien dans cette
région qui reconnaît ça
oui c'est une c'est là la preuve disons
d'une continuité historique comme l'a
dit monsieur vestiaires c'est à dire que
le pour les émirats il faut rappeler que
la fondation de la création de cette
fronde a fédération et le feq de cheikh
zayed qui était un grand admirateur du
général de gaulle c'est ça qui a été
l'argumentaire politique si vous voulez
qui a ouvert le marché aux armements
français
et puis d'autre part il faut bien penser
que l'arabie saoudite est depuis une
trentaine d'années le meilleur client de
la france en termes d'équipements de
défense en moyenne lissée bon donc ce
n'est pas une nouveauté
effectivement ce qui change aujourd'hui
et qui fait que le comment dire le débat
politique commence à prendre de
l'ampleur c'est surtout le fait que ces
pays n'utilisez pas les armes ils
achetaient des garanties de sécurité
j'avais les aoudia jusqu'à maintenant
acheter des armes uniquement parce
qu'ils voulaient se garantir que
français anglais et américain viendrez
les aider quand tu auras un problème il
avait tenté en 67 d'envoyer une régate
pendant la guerre des six jours elle est
arrivée trop tard donc là aujourd'hui le
problème c'est effectivement le yémen
c'est à dire que les les armes vendues
servent à massacrer des populations
civiles c'est pour ça que effectivement
il ya lieu de réfléchir à l'utilisation
des votes des armes vendues alors on va
évidemment abordé aussi ce point là mais
avant ça je voudrais qu'on reste un
instant sur l'aspect économique avec
vous j'ai un vestiaire emmanuel macron
s'est évidemment félicité de cette vente
elle démontrerait selon lui qu elle les
émirats considère la france comme un
partenaire solide et fiable qui tient
ses engagements ce sont les mots du chef
de l'état vente symbolique aussi parce
que c'est la première fois qu'un proche
allié des etats-unis dans le monde
arable dépendra davantage de la
technologie française que de la
technologie américaine
les choses sont peut-être un peu plus
complexe que cela n'est ce pas parce que
lors du développement de la mise en
place des accords abraham et bien les
états les émirats arabes unis donc dans
leur rapprochement avec israël dans ce
mouvement général
les etats-unis se sont engagés à livrer
à un chasseur de cinquième génération
donc encore plus récent le que le rafale
le fameux f35 dont des milliers
d'exemplaires où est construit pour les
armées dans le monde entier à nos yeux
il y a un jeu d'équilibré de la part des
émirats arabes unis entre justement leur
fournisseur américain et le fournisseur
français j'ajouterai que heil est prévue
dans cette dynamique là que israël qui
recevra aussi ses avions f-35 devra à
avoir une génération d'avancé sur ceux
livrés aux émirats muni alors peut-être
que les émirats ont souhaité avoir
effectivement une opportunité françaises
et la possibilité de démontrer une
certaine forme de d'indépendance de
pouvoir négocier plus facilement avec
les états unis alors vous l'avez donc
rappelé pierre connaissent à ce
déplacement des manuels macron ce
contrat interroge au vu du contexte vous
avez évoqué la guerre au yémen
rappelons aussi que les émirats arabes
unis ont été sous les projecteurs
il y a quelques semaines en raison
notamment de l'élection à la présidence
d'interpol de son candidat en général de
police visé par plusieurs plaintes pour
torture devant emmanuel macron deviendra
donc le premier dirigeant occidental
d'envergure à renouer officiellement
avec un mohammed bin salman depuis la
mort du journaliste et jamal rachedi que
demandent les français la france à ces
pays en matière de droits humains
c'est une question intéressante c'est à
dire on tient un discours
vous voulez vous faire de plus il faut
pas se fier luzio n'est si vous voulez
sur la nature des échanges
internationaux il ya effectivement des
ventes d'équipements de défense qui nous
garantissait pendant très longtemps
d'abord il faut bien comprendre le point
de vue de ces pays ces pays ne veulent
pas avoir un fournisseur unique c'est à
dire que ce qui les inquiète
particulièrement c'est le fait qu'ils ne
veulent pas être placée sous embargo
pendant longtemps c'était un risque de
guerre et qu'israël maintenant ce n'est
plus cas mais d'une manière générale
garder un ce1 second fournisseur est un
principe stratégique pour tous ces pays
de la région même le qatar pendant
lesquels nous avions la fourniture
exclusive de tous les équipements de
défense si tu commences à
s'approvisionner aussi aux états unis
donc ça c'est le point de vue des pays
du golfe pour ce qui concerne la france
il faut bien rendre compte aussi qu'il
ya une autre guerre qui est en arrière
fond c'est la guerre que nous faisons et
livre les américains c'est à dire que
les américains voudraient la pohdh
d'assaut il faut quand même penser qu'il
ya eu qu'un certain nombre de cas et je
rappellerai le cas des sous-marins en
australie où les américains a aidé cette
fois ci avec les britanniques souhaitent
la disparition de l'équipe de
l'industrie de défense française on
avait eu exactement des cas pareils en
arabie saoudite où faute d'assaut pensez
avoir vendu des mirage 2000 et puis la
veille même de la signature du contrat
on a appris que la vente était annulé
pour acheter des tornado
il faut penser aussi à cette guerre-là
en arrière fond évidemment il ya vous
avez le je pense pas que ce débat existe
aux états unis si vous voulez dans la
vente d'équipements de défense à
l'arabie saoudite ni à la vente aux
émirats donc on est sur une rivalité qui
a trois dimensions il ya une dimension
industrielle une dimension droit et
humaniste si vous voulez puis il ya une
dimension proprement militaires si vous
voulez dans cette rivalité avec les pays
anglo saxons dans la fourniture des pays
de la région
concernant j'ai un vestiaire cette
question des droits humains vous
partager le constat de pierre
connaissent à la france reste dans le
discours parce que ces trois pays et les
émirats arabes unis le qatar et l'arabie
saoudite sont des partenaires
stratégiques de la france au plan
économique notamment en quoi est-ce
qu'ils sont stratégiques
à jeu des places sera peut-être
légèrement le projecteur n'est ce pas
parce que la situation est minutes est
infiniment plus complexe et différente
de ce que l'on dit généralement ne faut
pas oublier que les outils ce n'est pas
une tribune soit c'est une famille qui
mène cette révolution depuis 1914 2014
pendance 2014 et bien le couvre que à
peu près un tiers du territoire il faut
savoir par exemple que et c'est une
révolution qui était fait dans la
violence qui a chassé
le président en place normalement élu en
2012 le président a dit et qu'a fait le
président a dit eh bien il s'est réfugié
en arabie saoudite est donc c'est ce
mouvement là qui a poussé l'arabie
saoudite à intervenir pour remettre en
place le pouvoir élu par les minimes et
par exemple je vous citerai une anecdote
je dirais malheureuse l'ambassadeur
actuel n'est ce pas du yémen à paris
était le ministre de la santé de
l'ancien gouvernement et bien à un
membre éminent de la famille outil est
arrivé dans le ministère avec la
kalachnikov lui a dit maintenant vous
prenez votre veste et vous sortez vous
prenez rien d'autre voilà comment les
choses se sont passées au yémen et
l'ancien président allié des outils a
été assassiné le jour où il a voulu nez
gossier avec l'arabie saoudite
donc le dossier est beaucoup plus
complexe et je pense différents de ce
qui est généralement
expliquées et en ce qui concerne donc
effectivement les relations avec
l'arabie saoudite et le dossier qu'à
chauny à appelons un chat un chat et
bien effectivement c'est un dossier
difficile mais
évitons de donner trop de leçons parce
que nous avons aussi que nul des
assassinats en france n'est ce pas de
ministres français qui y goûtent 33 ans
à robert boulin n'est toujours pas
élucidée donc voilà soyons très prudent
voyons avec une certaine distance les
événements il y a le côté moral des
choses et puis comme on l'appelle la
realpolitik et bien qu'elle ait ça
quelqu'un l'a existe-t-il aujourd'hui
concernant la vente d'armements est ce
que l'onu doit encadrer les conditions
dont il ya d'abord un système français
quand même il faut dire que quand une un
contrat est signé ou quand il est en
négociation vous avez une
d'un comité interministériel de contrôle
des exportations d'armements qui vérifie
l'invalidité politique si vous voulez
d'abord de la négociation ensuite de
lasser de la signature du contrat et
puis ensuite de la livraison donc on
n'est pas sur un système où les
industriels par tout cela c'est une
politique voulue et contrôlé alors
ensuite on peut discuter effectivement
des objectifs mais il n'y a pas dans le
cadre international de véritable
instance de contrôle il ya effectivement
des types d'armes qui sont interdites
les armes chimiques les armes
bactériologiques et ses râles et
certaines armes antipersonnel
mais fondamentalement personne n'a les
moyens de contrôler et donc on est sur
quelque chose où effectivement ça peut
être soit une un débat politique interne
dans les démocraties
soit éventuellement des campagnes
d'opposition absolue si vous voulez à la
vente de certains matériels à certains
pays mais on a bien vu si vous voulez
que quand il ya eu la guerre iran irak
dont je rappelle quand même que c'est et
l'irak qui était le pays agresseur
l'industrie française de défense a fait
des affaires en or avec le régime de
saddam hussein au point que quand le
pays est arrivé à la fin de l'année du
conflit
il nous devait 40 milliards $ et on n'a
fait aucun moyen de les encaisser donc
il ya toute une mécanique ce qui fait
qu'au bout d'un certain temps le
politique perd le contrôle de ses ventes
mais c'est ça qui est le principal
problème maintenant personne n'a nous à
nous donner de leçons âge de dire que ce
soit les états unis les russes les
anglais les allemands on est exactement
dans les mêmes situations chacun veut
sauver le type d'équipements de défense
dans lesquelles il excelle et pour ça
sert et souvent il ya peu de
frais moraux si vous voulez à la
négociation des contrats et j'espère on
vous entendait évoquer la realpolitik
vous dissocier donc l'aspect moral de
l'aspect économique vous n'êtes pas
favorable il ne faut pas qu l'onu
notamment encadre davantage ses contrats
de vente d'armement et ce sera le
dernier mot je crois qu'il faut qu'il y
ait une convergence si vous voulez entre
des intérêts industriels maintenant
l'importance de la technologie et des et
des développements technologiques donc
aucun pays ne peut se priver et puis
effectivement le droit la justice le le
sens et le respect des droits de l'homme
il faut qu'il y ait une convergence
maintenant cela dépend effectivement des
états cela dépend de l'organisation qui
se met en place autour de ces états donc
l'europe pour ce qui concerne est
effectivement la france et de ses
partenaires et puis l'onu comme vous
venez de l'évoquer donc le temps fera
espérons le son oeuvre pour ce que les
choses aillent vers la convergence mais
c'est une un voeu exprimé le
merci beaucoup à tous les deux géants
vespière analystes j'ai volé
géopolitique fondateurs du web magazine
le monde décrypté et pierre conesa
ancien haut fonctionnaire spécialiste
des questions stratégiques
internationales merci beaucoup et à
bientôt sur arte france vous